bonjour du coup je m'appelle calice man
suis et moi c'est Gabriel perron et on
élève à la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet en BTS production animale en
deuxième année aujourd'hui on se prépare
pour la finale nationale des Olympiades
qui aura lieu le 25 février au Salon de
l'Agriculture à Paris
sélectionné pendant le concours des
Olympiades elles affront une quarantaine
de candidats de toute la France qui
concourront pour le titre au salon de
l'agriculture
yvelinois seront soumises à des épreuves
théoriques et pratiques parmi elles
analyser l'état de santé d'un animal
mais pour cela il faut d'abord le
maîtriser j'ai analysé l'état de santé
de la brebis donc là on est sur une
brebis qui vient d'annuler il y a
quelques jours donc je vais commencer
par vérifier les onglons sous ses pattes
donc au niveau de la taille des onglons
s'il y a pas de maladie entre les
Anglais de champignons etc qui pourrait
te dérangeant et lui faire mal causer
des infections ensuite je vérifie la
mamelle
donc là elle est assez gonflée parce que
du coup elle vient d'annioler mais c'est
totalement normal elle est pas chaude ni
rien donc il y a pas d'infection de
mammite etc ensuite
j'ai regardé ses dents donc là elle est
dans bien Annie bien alignées elle a pas
de problème autre épreuve pour le
concours la note d'État corporelle des
agneaux destinés à l'abattoir d'abord on
parle les Pinder salles et puis les
flans donc les critères c'est si on peut
donc passer sous l'épine dorsale ou pas
si on sent bien la colonne vertébrale et
ensuite ce qu'on peut faire bon là il
est allongé c'est pas bien grave c'est
donc palper si on sent les les côtes ou
pas c'est une note qui se place entre 0
et 5 donc on part du principe que 0
c'est un animal mort et que 5 c'est un
animal en obésité morbide donc l'idéal
pour aller à l'abattoir ce sera un
animal qui serait à trois trois et demi
quoi au-delà de la performance c'est le
savoir faire et la mise en avant du
patrimoine local que les bergères
souhaite mettre en avant comme avec ce
bélier mérinos sur lequel elle
s’entraîne et dont l'espèce en France se
trouve seulement à Rambouillet donc là
c'est pas facile parce que il a la corne
assez molle vu que c'est l'hiver ils
sont en bâtiment donc c'est plus
difficile à couper malgré cette richesse
elles vont devoir se mesurer à la
concurrence la difficulté du de
l'épreuve et du salon avec les
concurrents c'est que nous avec Gabriel
on n'est pas
issu de la filière ovine contrairement à
certains concurrents qui seront nella
dedans fils d'éleveur ovin etc donc ça
va être un peu plus compliqué pour nous
c'est vraiment à nous de nous renseigner
et de connaître la filière sur le bout
des doigts leur première victoire reste
d'avoir été sélectionnée et de
représenter les couleurs de l'école au
salon de l'agriculture